I always want to like touch people on
the back of their neck yeah wow that's
an interesting one because I feel like
it's like the most kind of like it's
almost like a real parental place oh
yeah it's caring it's yeah so you you
mean you're the parent I don't know I
mean maybe I would dress up in a suit or
something but I don't know
if I would be like the parent but I I
just yeah sometimes I want to do that
even when I'm just talking to people I
want to like
how much like if I put my hand on the
back of their neck we would know more
about each other or something yeah you'd
be closer you'd be in arm's length away
yeah when I was in school in middle
school escape that moment yeah it's hard
to escape it so then I think you're
there with like the honesty of
whatever's really going on when I was in
Middle School if you got in a fight they
made you stand in the hall all day and
hug each other like this no [__] yeah
like what do you mean like your hands on
each other's shoulders on each other's
shoulders slow dance yeah yeah you and
another dude yeah yeah and you're both
going this is [__] yeah after for
how long oh probably I think I was out
there for four hours one time probably
no [__] yeah I mean this kid Brad cast
they're like blood on you from the fight
still and yeah still pretty dirtied up I
mean I was I will yeah he got the best
of me
but yeah we were out there and the kids
would come through during the like and
you try to be kind of cool like while it
was uh while it was like while while it
was in class you would try to like just
like be like you would kind of relax and
be cool with each other and yeah then
when the kids with the Bell would ring
and they would switch classes you'd be
like this is [__] gay dude right you
know you would like but then you're
alone out there during class time yeah
so you'd have to get to know each other
so you really would talk probably right
yeah I mean would there'd be like a
period of just like man [__] this [__]
you man yeah but then you start going
so what would you uh
like what are you doing after school or
why where do you you know is you have
sisters right Brothers yeah oh yeah you
get into it and then he became a friend
so I like that I think yeah there's
something about that smart idea the only
that pose of hands on shoulders
it reminds me of when I was I mean that
was middle school so this was
fifth sixth grade kids boys and girls
started saying they want to be boyfriend
girlfriend you know they started to be
that thing
and it was only the cool kids that could
do that like anybody that was below you
know in the nerdy or just not popular
anybody with glasses on was out oh no
you had no currency yeah but all the
cool kids got to hook up yeah and so
they would be like Mike McDougall and
Samantha
Amanda Stebbins these are real people
are gonna kiss and they and they did it
as a tribe too you didn't just walk up
to like I I walked up to girls and said
you want to be my girlfriend they're
like yeah flag of the play buddy that's
not how it's done
that's like somebody coming off the
sidelines and just getting in the play
hey give me the get the [__] out and
come in and just sip in your cream you
know yeah yeah
so you had to it would be like they'd
decide as a tribe Mike and Amanda are
gonna be a couple yeah so Amanda's
friends would push her and Mike's would
push him and they'd have to go to some
place and kiss not a tree or something
yeah and they would stand like that with
hands on shoulders just that exact and
they'd be like looking like trying to
look to the sides and everybody's going
come on and everything come on Mike you
[__] like [__] screaming at him
and he's like and Amanda don't be a you
know that just whatever and then
everybody goes
and one of them's stepdad was there too
like what does that do yeah yeah come on
Mike
but uh but it's a similar thing of kids
two young people trying to
your teach I never heard that your
school must have that's a really
creative and interesting I thought it
was it was one and me and that me and
that guy are still friends I just saw
him a couple weeks ago and I thought uh
but I'll do that thing just to talk
sometimes
once in a while it should be a regular
thing one shining mode yeah just sing a
little he was also [__] every weight
every hot waiter he was getting all the
[__] how are you supposed to like I
like that but but personally one-on-one
I really did like him a lot and then I
started I don't want to [__] him but I
would have [__] stood by I'm watching
put your hand on the back
yeah a little little of this with Joe
Rogan not bad yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one